Yes.
Society as a whole.
Then you're looking at it
from the wrong perspective.
Your,
your,
your level of analysis is wrong.
So you know it is society as a whole,
but what the hell good
is that going to do you,
you can't complain to society as a whole.
You have to look for the
micro manifestations that
actually occur in your realm
and work on those.
Yeah and that's the only level of analysis
you have any control over anyways.
Fix the things that are within your
realm of power and what will happen as a
consequence of that is that
your realm of power will grow,
but you start local because
like what the hell do you know?
You're 19 or 20 or whatever it is.
Like you have,
you have a scrap with society.
It's like that's just an
architectural problem.
That's all it is.
Because you don't know enough
about society to have that opinion.
You know?
And I'm not being,
I'm not being a like I'm not
trying to be cynical about this.
I am telling you it's an
architectural problem,
you know?
Of course,
everybody who is young has
a problem with society.
You're all at the bottom of the bloody
dominance hierarchy unless you count the
entire rest of the world,
in which case you're
already in the top 1%.
Right?
So you know,
that's where thinking about too.
So,
and you know,
if you,
if you are in involved in a battle,
in some sense with society,
you,
you're dominated by the
figure of the great father,
the negative figure of the great father.
You also have to a lot of
what you should do about that.
It's increased your level of gratitude.
You know,
here you are,
it's warm,
the chair works.
The floor isn't going to fall apart,
right?
You're at a prestigious institution,
you're well on your way to being
one of the top 1% in society.
You're just too damn young
right now for that to happen.
You're smart,
you're healthy,
you're good looking,
except for that weird thing
you're wearing around your head.
So like,
you know what the hell,
it's,
everything's good for you.
So I'm,
I mean,
I know there's a tyrannical
element there is,
it's real.
But,
but if that's all you see,
you're,
you're blinded and that's not good.
It'll warp you.